good morning everyone it's great to see
that so many of you are interested in
the material that's about like 2,000
years old so there the Chinese we're
doing a linear algebra I think actually
like 20 100 years ago at 2020 100 years
ago so it's very inspiring to see that
these things that all these great minds
developed a long time ago are still like
useful for us a useful tools that we use
every day yeah so today linear algebra
for those who do not know what it
actually is it's a branch of mathematics
that deals with matrices in vectors
that's basically all all I want to say
about the definition of linear algebra
but you could say like why linear
algebra well Morpheus already said that
the matrix is everywhere is all around
us even now in this very room
ok so what does that actually mean well
it is actually everywhere so for example
I'm just going to give a few examples of
applications of linear algebra now for
example Google the first search engine
they built was solely solely built on
linear algebra so were patreon so now
they developed it into something like
better and more complex but the first
search engine basically they represented
the whole Internet as a matrix and they
did some like linear algebra tricks and
and that's how they came up with like
good search results so this paper is
really highly recommended it's kind of
like explains how it actually works it's
called a twenty five billion dollar
eigenvector that like basically made
Google or big we can represent images as
matrix as many as many of you probably
know we can represent text in a matrix
that you can say like okay each column
is like a piece of each row is like a
piece of text and the columns indicate
which bruit are in the corresponding
piece of text and in data science is
it's pretty much everywhere it's used
for linear regression we will see that
later in this talk is used in the deep
learning computer vision multivariate
statistics if you think of like
principal component analysis for example
and also natural language processing
thing if you think of topic modeling for
example that heavily relies on on linear
algebra so what is the the purpose of
today it's going to be very non rigorous
overview of linear algebra it's more to
give you a bit of an intuition and a bit
more more like comfort of linear else
you have to get to get if you yeah in
your daily work touch up on these
subjects that you have a bit a bit of a
better understanding of what this
actually these things are like matrix
multiplication matrix decomposition
those kind of things so it helps you in
the end to understand analyze debug and
develop models models and algorithms
used in data science so we got basically
going to do three things first we're
gonna do a short like primer on matrices
and vectors like what are they actually
how this matrix multiplication work so
the very like fundamentals then we're
going to do like the geometry of
basically a linear regression it's gonna
be quite interesting and then we end
with matrix factorization and if time
allows I will show that actually the
second and the third topic are actually
really intertwined they really dependent
on each other if you want to call it
like that so let's start with the
vectors in the matrices so if you ask
for example a computer scientist what
does a vector he would just say like
just an array of anything it's just a
list of objects basically so here you
see a smaller example of that if you ask
to a physicist whether it's a vector it
would say like a vector describes a
force or velocity of a physical object
and this might be what you remember from
at least but I remember from doing
physics at high school yeah these
vectors that indicate how some object
moves or whatever we will go for like
the bit of a more like mathematical
definition of vectors it's like gives us
the most structure to do cool stuff and
it's like vector is a coordinate
relative to the origin so in this case
you see two dimensional plane and it
basically indicates somewhere these
where these let's say dot is in the
plane and of course this generalizes to
higher dimensions so in 3d you can still
make some sort of like think of how it
looks like what in higher dimensions all
those things works basically always the
same so what is that matrix matrix is
not not more than a collection of
vectors and if I talk about the vector I
mean a column vector so the vertical one
and what is in a matrix a matrix is
basically you can see there's a function
that
a vector to another vector so it takes
its input the vector and gives us out to
the vector as well we will see example
of that in a minute but before going
there like how does it actually work so
if you have a matrix I I hope this works
if you have a matrix you multiplied by a
vector what they're actually doing is
taking away that some of the matrix is
columns I really hope that someone would
have told me this like 20 years ago when
I was like in high school because this
is like the most at least for me the
most useful explanation of what matrix
vector multiplication is you see it here
you just take a sum of the red the blue
and the green column only you weigh it
according to the L to the corresponding
elements in the vector so these are also
means like if you do this then the
number of columns in the vector should
be equal to the number of elements in
the in the vector it's clear so for M so
we're going to illustrate now how this
matrix vector multiplication works by
rotating this image by 90 degrees
because clearly this image is rotated
and we would like to point it upwards
because it's not of any use now so what
we do we represent every pixel in this
picture by a vector so it's like the
first core the first element of the
vector is the x coordinates so it's like
on the horizontal axis the y coordinate
is the vertical let's say the vertical
let's say it plays and then the third
one is the grayscale so so that
indicates how gray how black or how wide
this pixel is so this is an example so
for example this one pixel over there
it's represented by this fourth four
thousand 2025 vector so we want to
rotate this thing so it turns out that
this matrix rotates each vector by 90
degrees in the counterclockwise
direction so how can we see that
actually the derivation is down there so
say that you multiply this matrix by any
vector this is just a matrix vector
multiplication that we saw in the
previous slide so we're assuming the
columns and you end up with this one so
the x and y are flipped and the y is x
minus one might still be a bit abstract
but let's see what it looks like so that
you have a vector here it's 4 1 if you
then pre multiply by this matrix it's
kind of like
it gets rotated by 90 degrees so this
this we can now do apply to this picture
this picture consists of 24 million
pixels and we just apply this matrix to
every pixel in the picture and then we
end up with a big bang pointing upwards
needless to say this is like the most
inefficient way to rotate the picture
because it takes like five minutes on
your laptop to do all those matrix
multiplications but it's just for the
sake of illustration yeah this is also a
good point to explain a matrix inverse
at least the intuition behind what a
matrix inverse is so here I'm not going
to into details how to compute the
matrix inverse put the matrix inverse
for this particular matrix it's exactly
the opposite transformation so back 90
degrees so that's like that it's just a
transformation in the opposite direction
so if you would apply the inverse here
you would end up with a rotated BIGBANG
again yes so now we're going to the
geometry of least squares I think this
is a very good topic for the purpose of
this talk because it involves a lot of
like things in linear algebra that you
come across often so we're gonna use
matrix manipulation vector norms
orthogonality matrix projections those
kind of things and the good thing is
everyone loves knows linear regression
so it's kind of like I think easier to
get your head around some some of these
topics so we're considering this example
we have like a linear regression model
with three observations so there's like
three coordinates in the two-dimensional
space and we're trying to fit the
straight line to the data basically so
this is just no thrills linear
regression and we observed observed data
and we're looking to estimate beta0 and
beta1 basically that's the whole point
Beata zero says like okay where does the
the red line hit the y-axis and beta one
sets the slope of this line basically so
what you could do is alkali we come up
with some score function in the mean
square error for example and we're going
to minimize the error that we are we try
to minimize choose the beta such that
the objective function is minimized
today with it so you can take like a
derivative
and well the algebra and whatnot but we
go for a geometrical approach and it
might be a bit abstract at first but I
think I really think it's an elegant way
of looking at this thing so bear with me
well first we have to do this sir so
what we first do is write this linear
regression model into matrix form so we
basically just what we are doing here is
as vincit like to call it we're just
saving ink so we collect collapsing all
these wise into a vector we call it Y
we're collapsing all the X's into one
matrix H so this is just rewriting it in
a like let's say a more efficient way
and if you if you do this matrix vector
multiplication thing again then you see
that you basically end up with the same
same things we're just written in a
different way
yes so if we point this if we come up
with some estimate a bit ahead at some
point then we can just make a prediction
let's say for Y by just doing the matrix
change multiplication x times beta head
so that's so far so how does this
geometrical interpretation of linear
regression looks like then well it looks
like this I'm going to take some time to
explain this you can think of this plane
as a piece of paper like in front of you
and this piece and this plane actually
represents all the estimates we can
potentially choose so every point in
this plane represents with a beta so it
also represents with a let's say
prediction for y so we can we can pick
any point in this plane however that is
why that we try to model this why is it
above the plane why is it above the
plane if the Y would be in the plane you
could it would be a beta that that would
be perfect fit we see that later but so
this Y is above this plane and we're
trying to find a point in the plane that
is as close as possible to Y well that's
in fact that's this one so that's the
one that is let's say perpendicular to
the plane that is where the that is that
that pertains to the beta hat that it's
like your best choice for for y so let's
get into detail a bit more so this is
what I just said so if they would if
this if this red vector would be in the
plane we could come up with a bit ahead
that fits Y perfectly and the best beta
hat is the one that's green one that is
the one such that E which is the error
that you make is y minus X beta is Earth
orthogonal but orthogonal means
perpendicular to the plane I really like
this picture but you might not but I
found it the first time super because
we're going to end up actually we're
going to show actually but the best for
the best beta is right now so what is it
so we have this notion of orthogonality
what does it actually mean this is going
to be there's not going to be a lot
mathematics in here but we have to we
have to do this otherwise we will get
stuck but the idea is is that you have
two vectors that point in very different
directions they are like perpendicular
and this is basically but orthogonality
is how does it work so if you have two
vectors V and W they're orthogonal if V
transpose W is equal to zero the
transpose is just flipping the vector to
a row vector basically so this is the
condition you have V and W it's like a
red and a blue vector and basically if
this sum of all these elements is zero
then they are orthogonal that point in
different directions basically you could
think of it as all these terms that are
like cancel out sorry yeah so they did
it's called orthogonality anyway so this
condition that we have here that we are
looking for this beta such that E is one
terminal or perpendicular to the plane
is actually bet conditional there so
just we say like okay X should be
perpendicular or the plane should be
perpendicular to the error that we make
then we can do some out so it's good to
note one thing on the side that we are
actually minimizing the length of e and
the length of a that is actually the
length of a vector we call that the norm
and if you if you write it down it's
actually what we are doing but it's not
maybe not surprising is we are
minimizing the root mean square error
but this is just a different perspective
to it yeah and now we can just do some
basically you with matrices you can also
do some algebra so I won't go into
detail here but you can do some algebra
and then end up with your estimate to be
head beta head sorry and that you can
just compute by using
mmm pie for example so as an alternative
if you would this is an alternative like
way of thinking of linear regression and
coming up with the beat ahead that is
the best fit to your model the second
thing I wanted to talk to today was
sorry matrix factorization because it is
used in machine learning and data
science actually a lot so matrix
decomposition is about decomposing
decomposing matrix into other matrices
so for example here for matrix a you
might decompose it in in B and C and it
can be like B times C or B plus C why
would you do it for example data
compression we will see that in a bit
numerical benefits because it may be
faster to use a vectorized matrix and
often it also provides insight into the
structure of the matrix that we will
also see in a bit there are many matrix
factorization go look on Wikipedia the
list is long and they have all different
kinds of like properties and those kind
of things but today people look at
singular value decomposition because
it's I think the most famous and most
used matrix decomposition out there is
used in natural language processing is
used to do actually principal component
analysis data compression linear
regression and for recommender systems
as well the people that want the Netflix
prize the thing they use singular value
decomposition or at least approximation
of it to to win this prize I don't know
ten years ago or so so this is a bit of
a primer to see what we are working
towards and I will explain after this
how we get to you this is the picture of
the Big Bang again oh sorry and
basically what you see here is or this
was a mistake but basically the fifth
one is assume of the first five one so
we can like decompose the picture into
different layers and then you see if you
combine them you end up you might think
that is a bit of a shady blurred picture
but we are using only 0.04 percent of
all the data so that's that's the thing
here we can decompose the picture we can
like pull it apart and we can we can
save a lot of let's say memory by that
and and how does this actually work
so any matrix so this is an example of a
four by three matrix you can be
composing three matrices they often
called us and V but that's just up to
any
to name them and yeah so you decompose
them in u.s. mvu is like the full matrix
v is a full matrix as well but s is like
diagonal so only the elements on the
diagonal value the other ones is zero
you might think okay like why is this
useful but it turns out that is us and V
are special like properties that we can
use to do data compression for example
this is just doing the so this step is
just doing the basically matrix
multiplication so what we see here is
that this is this is equal what you see
what you get if you get if you take a
column vector and you multiply by row
vector you get a full matrix so it is
basically the sum of three matrices and
we will see now why that actually helps
us in anyway because you might think oh
why do we why do we do all this as I
just said this is U and V there are
special properties the the norm or the
length of each column of U and each row
of V they have a length of one so what
how does it help us if you if you if you
do that multiplication so the column
times row you get a matrix it kind of
tells you that each element in that
matrix will not be very let's say large
because the length of the column vector
is one so the elements are typically
smaller than one if you want to kind of
like and this blue one so that's that
comes from the diagonal of this edge
there are larger than zero so basically
this is this blue one that kind of like
determines the magnitude of the matrix
because the elements of the green one
times red one are all like small and
then it's the blue one that determines
okay how large are the numbers going to
be in this matrix and this is super
important super important super useful
because you could say I'm only using the
one that is that large the blue one that
has the largest value and I throw away
the rest because this the the one that
has the largest value that it's the one
that matters most
all so over this like on a sidenote each
of these for example the columns in the
green one and you they're orthogonal to
each other so they point in different
directions so each column contains very
different information that's like
they're at least how I try to convince
myself how this works and so
for the Big Ben if we do this whole
thing by the way these blue values are
called singular values you might have
heard of them at some point they're used
so if you do this whole trick but then
for the Big Ben and you only take the
one that corresponds with the largest
being value you get the picture of it
there so it's it's like the let's say
you can say like the contours of the
power that mattered them arm like the
most important for this picture you see
that okay if we if we only use the
largest singular value then all we
basically get is the position of the big
band but rest is like bit blurry but we
are using very little data here so what
happens if we start using okay the code
we're gonna skip this is just as a
reference if you check this light light
you can see how this works it's not so
difficult but how does this work if we
if we like start adding more data so
this is the one we saw before we only
use the further largest singular value
and that gives you like the location of
the Big Ben and we we only using 0.05
percent of the data here but yeah it
doesn't give us much either so you think
like okay this is not useful okay if we
also add like the second the second
singular value it starts to look like
something of a tower well maybe because
we know but at least it looks a bit
better you really see that it has a top
and then there's a building if they like
three start to recognize it but still we
were only using 0.15 percent of all the
of all the data so we're getting
somewhere
the point is the picture gets better
really quick that's the whole point of
this exercise
you only need like not so many of these
singular values to represent the picture
in a meaningful way because this is all
this is five but if we increase it a bit
more we said like 10 now we start
recognizing things we said like oh it's
like other buildings in the picture the
big band also has a clock apparently and
still we're only using half a percent of
all the data and this is 20 so we use
the sin of the first 20 and this is like
50 and you almost already retrieve the
whole picture by using only two and a
half percent of all the data and if you
go to five hundred you basically recover
almost the whole picture
and still using only 25% of the data as
a side note this exact same trick you
can you can apply to for example text
and that's well that's how you do
basically topic modeling then the the
most important topics of text that
correspond to the largest senior values
so this is how you can also apply this
tool for example natural language
processing so it's funny to see that
this technique is so generic that it
works in many applications if you so but
it is that we don't have time to discuss
that but I think it's super useful so
this whole idea that only the largest
singular values matter I try to plot it
here what do we see on the x-axis you
see these singular values so this is
like if we go back to this to his
decomposition so I took all the the ones
in the blue matrix so that's the that's
the veldt that's the values that
indicate what matters the most and I put
them in this plot and on the y-axis is
their value and it's in log scale so you
see that the first singular values are
around like 10 million or so and that is
where you really already start to see
this power coming up the big band coming
up from this picture but then you see
like the the the value of this singular
values it declines super fast so already
like the 500 largest singular value is
like around what is it ten thousand
percent so already compared to the the
first few ones it doesn't really do much
so that's the whole idea of doing the
singular value decomposition so now I
like to go back actually to the geology
of these squares because like I know 15
minutes ago where this whole thing about
the geometry of linear regression I hope
you still remember it so we had this
picture and after quite some let's say
reasoning and some little bit of algebra
we ended up with this thing and yeah so
you might think like okay but we are
finished here right now the whole point
is if you do for example in SK learn
linear regression some first let's say
so you could do this so you could
actually compute this in
new pie so you just do like Mumbai ly
and LZ by the inverse of X transpose
times X and then time to experience
close why so you could think that's fine
we're finished does anyone know why this
is not a not a good idea to do this the
inverse is bad inverse is really bad
yeah a time allows them some examples
but as one of the messages I like to say
here trying not to invert matrices
numerically because it's numerically
unstable as we say what does it mean you
just if you invert a matrix you just not
gonna get a real like value if you can
it's gonna be distorted so if you can
not information correctly always not do
it so this is the reason why this is
like super interesting I think
actually to compute it for SK learn to
compute this that you singular value
decomposition so that's super surprising
so first we're using a very cool just do
this whole like image trick and as it
turns out SK learn also using a level of
decomposition to compute our regression
coefficients so how does that work so we
start with this this estimator that we
derived the beta hat what actually is
happening is that I do a senior value D
conversation on X this is numerically
very stable not super fast out but it's
numerically stable then this is homework
you fill in the the result of the of the
singular value decomposition in the beta
hat you have to do some algebra may be
fun on your way back and say him it's a
super special property that V and and
for V and u it turns out that the
transpose so flipping it by 90 degrees
it's the same mistake in the inverse and
this is quite special because this is
normally not a case but that property
you can use to derive that the beta is
actually then actually equal to this so
this is how if you do linear regression
in a scalar and this is what happens
like in the roots or they do a or a
different factorization with either
singular value decomposition or I think
QR decomposition is a different one
anyways it's factor matrix factorization
that that eskalene's to computer or
regression coefficients so what did we
do first of all we did the geometric
interpretation to linear algebra we
talked about matrix actresses major
vacations norms orthogonality these
squares estimation and matrix
factorization I see that I have some
time left I don't know first I have to
recommend this one so it's good that I
have some time left these are two
sources that are highly recommended if
you like this stuff the first one is
like YouTube let's say YouTube is a
playlist or whatever list of videos it's
made by it's called three blue one Brown
I don't know how we did it but it's like
a visualization of all kinds of very
abstract linear algebra topics like
eigenvectors eigenvalues it but also
matrix D comes like basically it stuff
it starts from the very beginning and it
ends up all the way a very complex
things this is really as if you are like
in the matrix I didn't know I don't know
how apparently he open-source the coltan
we made it because it's like a super
cool visualization and these things that
I've been using for years also doing my
PhD that I only like really understood
after watching those videos then the
second one and this this comment is
super funny so it says who is the
monster that topping my teased but
forgot to tell me about the origin and
beauty so that hits the name of the
second one if you want to do more like
course touting there's an hour faster a
course on numeric a numerical linear
algebra it's also really good I actually
landed quite some things from that
course also for this talk I want to say
thank you if time allows I want to say
one more thing about numerical about
unstable matrices because the time
allows so you might think like why why
should I not invert matrices numerically
a very good example of a matrix that is
where [ __ ] goes totally bad if you
invert it is the hill Hilbert matrix so
it's kind of it looks for this for three
dimensions you can kind of like see the
how it propagates but if you can expand
it to more it's basically you kind of
see the structure from it if you invert
this thing then stuff goes wrong so I
think I do have time so I will do it so
you expect so this is the first
observation you expect if you do like a
inverse times a times V that you end up
with V again for any vector think of the
picture if you rotate it 90 degrees and
then take inverse
and rotated back you expect to end up
with the same thing again this is stupid
anyway so what you do I can tell what
what returns is that so if you do this
for a matrix of ten by ten you make the
Hilbert matrix using as side by Lin off
so what do you expect if you do the
inverse of a you see that the bottom if
you multiply the inverse of a by a times
V and V is just to make a vector once
you expect to return the matrix of once
well the thing is try it at home you
don't get back may add a vector with
ones it's gonna be like already large
deviations that you see so I think I
print the minimum here it's like 0.99 or
so so you already have like a huge
deviation from one so this is just yeah
that was just like last message on
inverting a matrix matrices the
numerically so thank you for your thank
you for attention I hope you liked it
and if you have any questions I think we
have time
[Applause]
yeah put your hands up if you got any
questions is there anything else you
wanna talk about there's a lot of time
yeah no I immediate I wasn't really
wondering like what are people even
gonna ask because it's not really it's
more like a lecture than I yeah you
wanna plug yeah so we have a very cool
competition going on with goda driven
you can win a lego books maybe you saw
it so if we ever stand over here go
David within our company and we have
kind of like set up a competition which
you can win the Lego books as a few
hours left so if you like to solve a
very difficult combinatorial problem and
win a Lego box then go for it it's yeah
for the rest I don't think I have much
to tell so that we can just go to yeah
no there's nothing all right let's give
a round oh no oh hey what's the software
you used to convert the markdown to the
visitation I used it for the first time
for this one I really liked it
it's called dick [ __ ] dick [ __ ] it's
called yeah it the cool thing we have
time anyway the cool thing you can
choose like team very easily and then it
starts to look it looks amazing
even if someone like me who is like
really shitty at making slides look nice
then it really helps you and it also
helps you to not too much not to put too
much on the slide because you basically
it just doesn't fit if you just keep
adding stuff it will just fall off the
slides or little bit kind of like
prevents you from having very long away
stuff okay now we fix it so yeah exactly
yeah
exit visa so so yeah we shot we saw sort
of inverses and like SPG and that's our
thing is there any sort of other like
topic in linear algebra there's like
super cool not to ignore eigenvalues I
think this is the one thing I did not
have it turned out that would have had
time to do it but I think I give values
are I think most used and least
understood like at least from an
intuition perspective and they pop up
basically everywhere it's unbelievable
but I would really and then then I would
recommend a YouTube videos because
they're they have a super good
explanation of how eigenvectors
eigenvalues work and what they actually
are they're actually very much related
to singular value decomposition so it's
that's what I would recommend yeah very
good talk thank you um could you give us
some examples to how this is applied
maybe a bit more advanced than the one
that you showed they were you know
example from your own experience where
this really was really important for you
today of time and I think where linear
algebra is most use at least is in
implementing computations fast I did not
want to go in there because I think this
for me this was more interesting but the
idea that by vectorizing code so for
example by using the umpire identify for
example if you do like this deep these
deep learning things intentional fall
that's where there's a lot of value from
like computational gain by using linear
algebra I'm putting stuff in matrices
because of the way they are like
implemented in for example Mumbai
they're like super fast and they run on
I don't know some low-level code so that
is where they are I think mostly where
linear algebra is mostly super useful by
getting rid of for loops and vectorizing
stuff and making sure that things go
super fast
yeah other things is for example what a
linear algebra is also often use I don't
know if you're into like markov decision
processes and markov processes these
kind of things there is like also often
use because then the matrix and I'm not
going to detail too much but there there
linear algebra is also often used yeah I
don't know other things I'm missing but
okay yeah so yeah just stay and finish
and we'll give you some other examples
but yeah that's the it okay I'll see you
around rules please
[Applause]